an é inútil surra de paumole e ii lado o
lado pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que
sejam muito bem vindos já mais um vídeo
e arroz trago já que j 11
o jogador luso ontem quer dizer que nós
já temos um novo ânimo à sony e tamanho
assustador o caso só lhe falta em um dos
braços e já voltei atrás ela aparece
todas aqui pop e não para o pessoal não
ocuparem nessa bosta de condenar
qualquer edifício baixar um pouco os
gráficos que o jogo porque eu quero
fazer um vídeo a 60 frames e por isso
teve que baixar os gráficos por como
esse é uma bosta mas em breve já vou ter
uma placa de vídeo nova por isso mesmo
só prestar ok vamos lá então jogar e
quando você chega a ignited chica ok já
começou o objetivo é apanhar dez
desenhos em cinco minutos e até já o
peixe já consultar mais escuro como
assim o celular foi ótimo e mesmo na
floresta estão muito fluidas style é
muito lenda olha que já um design o
cônsul já começou assim o timão nos
vossos comentários não tem vídeo e
relançou foxy e vocês disseram para
apontar a flash lite pra cara dele olha
que já é um sonho quando eu tivesse com
jorge branco certo eu vou tentar fazer
isso agora com o chicó cai porque o pai
que ela tinha um bigode branco cheguei
não pude fazer nada porque eu era bem
rápida
é o [ __ ] design vai embora muito
apanhar o design o crédito já que tom
candiota estamos muito bem eu tenho que
seguir este caminho assim não sei se
deveria por aqui é que parece tudo muito
exposto né
vamos entrar no meio do bosque embora só
foi o caminho em bora bora bora bora é
melhor pagar a luz não é exato eu acho
que é melhor andar assim eu vou tentar
andar sem flash lite quando chega por
ser aí sim o cena flash lite eu acho que
essa é a melhor estratégia holística
calma com que eu consiga chegar lá um
disco com ó macaé
começamos no mesmo sítio parece que não
eu acho que não começamos num sítio não
está totalmente rendam olha e joãozinho
não é igual é ou não olha já não sai
torneio o que já temos
o design precisamos que desde o botafogo
é muito do sangue já apanhei 108 aqui
outro lá e isso temos dois pessoal só
nos faltam oito é eu sei fazer conta e
só que tem dois caminhos esquerda
direita já não sou [ __ ] se vamos ou
esquerdo michel outro dizendo que eu
sabia que estaria paquerando agora para
a companhia e só aí isso ó ó pará chega
quando quando quase pessoal a técnica
funciona o coxinha também que o poder
fosse vai pro jogo dele funcionou
ok agora 'socorro socorro' olha o design
by vai muito rápido marco porque está em
arcore estar colo chi conectar e está
muito escuro não dá pra ver [ __ ]
nenhuma aí o meu cozinho custoso está a
apanhar frio nesta floresta assombrosa
que o destino contador de histórias eu
já não sei onde é que o twitter não sei
eu estou completamente perdido eu já
olhando uma luz só que aí é problema
para mim eu vou tentar seguir os lusos
de então eu acho que já dei porque acho
que terá aporte inicial nef que o
conselho julgar vamos mais lá para a
frente a outro uso ao fundo eu vou
tentar chegar até ele e lhe um design
onde sei não acho que não é uma luxuosa
faca
ai ai ganham um design já muito rápido
aqui está outro design exatamente o
ponto é sempre o mesmo nós começamos é
sempre o mesmo quer dizer que se eu
procurar onde vou apanhar os designers
eu consigo passar o jogo mais pra frente
vou tentar fazer isso ok havia mais
ninguém sabe exatamente eu estou sempre
no mesmo sítio a espanha este agora acho
que tinha outra que ao curso eu acho que
vi aqui um carácter eu
isso foge por suas posturas com cielo
quase como ganhava não ficar muito tempo
mesmo quando ela vir atrás de mim filha
da mãe sai de que nela não quero
companhia chica vai embora mais e frango
vai cai cry fique trancado na árvore
meu deus ela continua a transmitir
socorro socorro socorro acho que já
conquistei com a marca principais nos
manda que ela já não há páginas de quim
fica aí chica chica chica boom chic a
tapar-lhe meu deus meu culto à memória
do herói que o design ea espanha rápido
ai ai
ai ai ai está muito triste o que está
morando ali chico pedro canga olha outro
design já vi já vi já vi já bem calma
calma vai lá rápido muito rápido fica
aqui perto
vai pra [ __ ] isso vai ficar
prejudicado ok faltam 15 já ganhamos
mutado pessoal temos de 50% jogo não
sendo eu tô será que todo o mato onde
além de 16 anos bora lá vai e rápido e é
isso que está muito perto de mim já o
lixo o fundo corre caraças vai faltar um
dos quatro está quase na quarta 4 quando
a passar esta [ __ ] acho que tem outro
designer a não é só uma luz jazz e ache
que eu ficar estica alta 135 ti e não
encontra nada
não há nada sua árvore olha o design é
será será outro dizem é todo 13 [ __ ]
aí ela quase foi embora
foto 1 337 pessoas só com 13 na holanda
que o estoque não sei se aqui a desenhou
não eu acho que já passei que eu acho ai
ai ai qual acompanhou foto aí ache que é
ficar aí parado e chica eu não encontrei
nada agora a falta falta um minuto falta
um minuto e pouco se encontra o trecho 3
marcando lamechice cool mexe se o curso
for com três páginas a checar se ela
está muito perto que eu já vi todas as
árvores já vi tudo num encontro mais
desenhos bota quase que ela apanhou o
meu deus eu e apreço ninja da flash lite
anda lá lá lá um aviso de que não há não
é impossível este jogo é impossível já
perdeu já perdi o fato 24 segundos nos a
perder
eu já perdi muito mas deixa bem ok era
não dar meu não da falta de segurança
falta desconte novo 8h já planejar
produzir já vão morrer não há desânimo
não há o objetivo foi o confronto acabou
acabou e agora quer que as possam fazer
é andar aqui à toa olha que outro design
um a sério é sério agora com o tempo
acaba que o encontro de design muito
obrigado o peru que o é chicago eu só
que se for feita fora da cerca como
assim
agora o que eu posso fazer é tentar
descobrir onde
juntos design e quanto ela não ia
apanhar a chica tem calma contigo será
que eu estou no chão assim já possui
muito mais do tempo e nozinho não
adianta eu só estava à procura dos
mexicanos gael kakuta que uma página já
há a meu tá muito difícil steel cabo é
difícil
olha aqui outra eu vou tentar seguir
agora o caminho e não se ir muito daqui
e ver se conseguia encontrar alguma
página aqui faltam três pessoal tão
esperto estamos muito perto agora eu
cozinho a [ __ ] chica a concentração é
real desta idéia de gênio concentração
falta de três páginas pessoal estamos
com mais de um minuto tem que andar aqui
mais perto da cerca eu já procurei la
numa e agora tô assim mais pertences de
cerca de ver se conseguia encontrar
alguma coisa aqui outra foto duas
pegaram duas ruas cururupu xuxa foto 1
do ranking páginas falava lado cada vez
mais perto então haja política aprendi
eu recebi que faltavam 24 páginas sétimo
eu não consigo eu já tô aqui há mais de
uma hora a jogar e eu não consegui
passar a portaria deste mapa e do
edifício faltavam duas páginas apenas
pessoal digam me onde é que as duas
partes estavam o que não faltava espero
que vocês tenham gostado pessoal quando
eu falei que favorito fiquem vai até a
próxima